but first our top story this hour we
continue to help celebrate queen
elizabeth's platinum jubilee for
centuries in britain the clothes a
monarch wore played an important part in
conveying their power and status with
ornate fabrics and luxurious designs as
queen elizabeth celebrates 70 years on
the throne holly williams found out how
today's queen still dresses to send a
message
she's one of the most recognizable most
photographed women on the planet and
it's been that way for her 70 years on
the throne
she's known for her religious sense of
duty her service to the nation my lord's
prereceited
she's representing an institution
that has
clung to its traditions for centuries
against a backdrop of seismic change and
her iconic style according to kenya hunt
the editor of british l magazine that
silhouette that she sticks with in terms
of her suit and the hat and the bag and
the shoe which is a very sensible heel
it you know it's um it's a very clear
branding we look we don't even have to
see her face you could just look at the
woman and block out the face and we
automatically know that it's the queen
and so that's a very powerful image
her signature look has barely changed in
decades and comes in a range of very
bright block colors color does convey a
sense of hope and optimism oftentimes
you see women politicians who gravitate
towards colors that tend to be a little
more dark darker and more serious like
black navy blue
and beige whereas the queen is really
quite light
amanda wakeley is a fashion designer
who's famously dressed many of the
younger royals from diana to kate and
megan are there things that royals need
to consider when they're dressing that
ordinary mortals don't oh
a lot i know she's very conscious of
not wearing a hat too low over her face
because again if the crowd has come to
see the queen or the audience has come
to see the queen they want to see her
eyes as well as literally hundreds of
lenses trained on them when they're in
yeah
every angle so
you know it's the hair has got to be
perfect 360.
she told us the queen knows exactly what
works best for her
i think the most stylish women i know
have found their uniform have found
their style and they just stick with it
and they stick with it versions of it
and then they're really comfortable in
their skin
and comfort is her watchword for over 60
years she's been carrying elegant
utilitarian handbags made by launa and
her sturdy heels by anello and david are
first worn in by her dresser angela
kelly to prevent them rubbing kelly's
been a trusted aide for 20 years and
recently published a discreet book about
her work with the monarch
wakeley says the queen's style is less
about fashion than a statement of intent
i'm no nonsense i'm here to do a job and
serve my nation
the queen has met plenty of fashion
icons through the decades from jackie
kennedy to sophia loren and michelle
obama
the queen's crimson rogue and she's had
her own high fashion moments yards of
regal silk for her coronation designed
by norman hartnell
the cover of british vogue this past
april and in 2018 the queen attended
london fashion week for the first time a
study in contrast with vogue editor anna
winter her off-duty style is very
different a country girl at heart
according to those who know her happiest
with her horses
and her beloved corgi dogs it gives the
you know people a different window into
her life and and i guess it reminds you
that she's you know there are different
sides to this woman if you were
appointed her stylist tomorrow what
would you do would you shake things up a
little bit
she is a woman in her ninth decade she's
nailed her look and she's comfortable in
it she looks fabulous in it
no absolutely not i think i think she
does us all proud
for cbs saturday morning holly williams
london
who am i to say but she has a range of
style if you ask me you know she she
she's mixed it up through the years
certainly age well i think with the time
yeah i think with the time she's changed
the colors i i love the colors and you
were saying the hat i love
the question is does she ever sell the
hats consignment perhaps donations or
where are they
we need to get you guys someone who can
break in your shoes i know that actually
that would be nice i mean that's my that
might be my present this year right to
both of you
or just hats well you could do it for us
i think both of us have bigger feet than
you too
we'll talk about it